all right we're in the homestretch of
this first I guess we could have called
almost experimental section but
hopefully it's been it's been working
out decently so we're on number 17
number 17 and it says if a plus 2 times
X plus 1 is equal to s what is X plus 1
in terms of SN a so X plus 1 is that
essentially equal to what so let's just
take this equation a plus so what
happens if we subtract a from both sides
well we get 2 times X plus 1 is equal to
s minus a all right I just subtracted a
from both sides let me switch colors and
then if we divide both sides by 2 we get
X plus 1 is equal to s minus a over 2
and I think we're done that's it that
was choice B and it was actually
surprising to see a problem that took so
little time this late into the tasks
they normally get kind of harder as you
go through and and I guess the reason
why this is a little tricky is a lot of
people's initial would be I don't know
initial motivation would be to try to
solve for X and then try to figure out
what X plus 1 equals but the trick is to
just not break apart this X plus 1 I
mean you could kind of view this as a
variable once again like we a couple of
problems ago where you don't you have to
avoid distributing this two out if you
just keep it as X plus 1 and you solve
for X plus 1 you get very quickly 2's
minus 8 over 2 which is choice B the
next problem number 18 we are in the
homestretch and this is normally when
the problems get on the difficult side
so let me clear this because this looks
like it might take some space in which
invert colors so shaded region above so
let me draw the shaded region above so
let me see this is that's the y-axis oh
man I want to draw it straight but
anyway I'll deal I'll deal can't always
be perfect
so this is the y-axis this is the x-axis
and then I have this neat looking curve
it looks something like this something
like this
alright the clear keeps going and it's
let's see it draws off some points so
it's like you know one two three four
and that draws this boundary line here
it draws this this boundary line at four
so it's like this and then they shade
they shade the region and I have a
feeling they're gonna ask about the
shaded region so let's also actually let
me let me cuz I'm gonna use it the
shaded in dual so let me let me make
sure that I I don't end up filling up
the whole screen so I want to make sure
that I close all the gaps so now let me
use the shaded in tool shaded in tool ah
their work done all right so what are
they saying
the shaded region of the figure above
the shaded region and the figure above
is bounded by the x-axis that's this the
line x equals 4 that's this line right
and the graph y equals f of X that's
this that's the brown line y is equal to
f I never used gray maybe I should use
gray something I know I don't like gray
anyway
green if the point a B lies in the
shaded region so they did we don't know
where it's someplace in this movie's a
darker color let me use maybe blue this
point a B a B is someplace in this
shaded region which of the following
must be true and they have choice number
one not to use a lighter color choice
number one is that a is less than or
equal to four
choice number two is that B is less than
or equal to a and choice number three is
that
B is less than or equal to F of a F of a
interesting so we know that a B is in
this gray region so it's someplace you
know around there so let's so if that's
a B so that means at this point and it's
not exact a B could have been anywhere
in this gray area but let's say that
this point is a and we know that this
point if we just write here is B so we
know a couple of things we know that a
is someplace between zero between zero
and four right we know a is someplace
between zero and four so that means that
a is less than or equal to four because
it can be it could it could be four
because we're including the boundary so
this is correct we know this is true
let's see we also know well we don't we
don't know whether let's see B is less
than a how can we come to that
conclusion because I mean if the point
was if we had the point that was like
right well even where it's here but if
let's see at this point let's say that
this point was our a B then I mean just
eyeballing it just looking at the graph
it just looks I mean we don't know we
did I mean it looks like B in this
situation would be larger than a right
so I I definitely don't think we can
make that conclusion at least there's no
obvious way to make that conclusion
all right B could because we don't know
what f of X is f of X could be you know
really steep and have a really high
slope in which case B would grow faster
than a at this point you know and
earlier on so I don't think that this is
right so this is not right and then
let's see is B less than F of a so what
is f of a if this is point a what is f
of a well F of a is going to be right
here
this is f of a alright this is f of a
and no matter where you draw it B is
definitely going to be less than F of a
if you if you if you picked it this is
our point right and if you said that
this is B and that this is a then this
would be F of a
this would be F of a and bloody red and
B would still be less than F of a right
because no matter because B is in the
shaded region that is less than F of a
essentially so we also know that this
last term is correct hopefully that
makes sense if this one doesn't make
sense I want you to experiment with it
and and you'll you'll see but we're
essentially saying that the point is is
in the you know it's all the X it's all
the Y values less than f of X right this
is a shaded region essentially so let's
see what choice is that 1 & 3 1 & 3 only
that is choice D D as in dog all right
number 19 I don't know if we have time
for this might have to do it in the in
the next video actually let's just do it
in the next video cuz have two more
problems and I'm gonna have to have
another video no matter what so I'll see
you in the next video